[Music]
pam is in atlanta hi pam welcome to the
ramsay show
hey
how's everybody great how can we help
today
okay so um i am calling because my
husband and i
have finally decided that we need to um
we need to take care of our our
financial situation good um
about
three or four years ago
his aunt handed us the total money
makeover book and we
took it
um and we were like no we're okay we're
surviving used it
okay it was a coaster yeah well then we
passed it along to another family member
and said oh you might need this more
than we do
and
we're finally tired of
surviving we're we're tired of you know
the paycheck to paycheck and we have
everything we need
but i think she's ready george nothing
to
do
that's the biggest step of all i'm proud
of
so well thank you give us a picture a
snapshot of your financial picture
what's your income and how much debt do
you guys have
okay so um
before taxes were right at 1 30 we bring
home 98.8 a year that's between the two
of us
um debt is
about 76 000
um
also we have um we kind of built our
home
um
well we didn't kind of we built our home
ourselves my husband really built it on
some family land so
kind of like a barn dominium so we have
no mortgage um
so all of that debt is credit card loans
and then two car payments
yeah so
we i have i have ordered the book i
ordered how can we best help you today
okay so i ordered the book from amazon
they sent me the wrong book
um and i sent it back and now they're
supposedly sending me the right one
and i guess i just need
i need to hear
um i need you to tell me like just push
me in that direction
um
i don't want to say i'm a skeptic
but you know i do a budget every quarter
um i used to do an annual budget and it
never worked it always fell apart it
doesn't work
so i started doing it
yeah so i started doing an um a quarter
i quarterly didn't work either
yeah that's
sometimes some months at work and then
some months it doesn't work yeah
because every every month is different
right and you're trying to operate off a
template
instead of instead of reality
this is correct and so it won't work
unless you do one before the month
begins each and every month because that
way you're customizing what my income is
that month i know exactly what it's
going to be for the coming month in
almost every case and i know exactly
what my expenses are going to be or are
really good accurate uh projection of
them and so you take all of your income
and you give every one of those dollars
a name a mission before the month begins
and here's the hard part
any goober can do that you can do that
on a yellow pad okay it's sixth grade
math third grade math
all right but the trick is then to
actually use that through the whole
month and not do anything with money
except what's on that paper
right and you and your husband pinky
swear
and spit shake and agree to this is a
freaking contract
and so the way we always used to teach
it in the old days in fpu and it still
applies today is
remember when you were a little kid i
was a little kid my little sister would
say you're not the boss of me
and that's the deal with the budget the
budget is not the boss of you
you get to tell the budget what it's
going to do
until the budget is done
and then the budget becomes the boss of
you right but you're the boss of it
until it's down on that paper and then
it's telling you what to do so it's
saying no pizza tonight goober you're 76
000 in debt stay at home and eat
leftovers that's the budget bossing you
around but if you're not looking at it
and going we're over we're about to go
over on our food budget you won't stay
home you'll look back at the end of the
month and go oh we went over on our
budget again budgets don't work no you
didn't stick to it budgets work if you
stick to them
right but you can't do that on a
quarterly or annual basis it does not
work though
so okay that that's the part of the
budget thing that works and then we're
going to show you the whole system
to get you completely out of debt
and become wealthy all the way through
spoiler alert but then the trick is you
got to do every one of the steps
okay and if you think we're wrong we're
not you are
we've shown 10 million people how to do
this i don't know anything about
anything but this stuff i got it dialed
in
and pam the average the average person
to do this stuff they'll get out of debt
within 18 to 24 months if they get on a
budget they get serious they start
making some sacrifices and based on the
numbers you laid out that's you guys you
can do this stuff and you've got money
coming out of your check for retirement
and and or big health insurance or
something else because you got too much
coming out of your check
yeah yeah it's
health insurance and 401k for months
yeah so you're going to stop your 401k
temporarily are you getting a big tax
refund too
um not big no usually between 12 and
1500. okay all right then that's only
100 a month too much is coming out of
your check for taxes
okay so we adjust that a little bit but
not much
and then we're just going to get on
beans and rice rice and beans because we
want to be out of debt more than we care
what somebody thinks and that might mean
selling a car it might mean not it will
mean not going on vacation or going out
to eat until you clean up this freaking
mess you made and then you're gonna be
free what would it be like to have no
payments in the world
that would be awesome now we our next
step after um
we would like to
either purchase or build a house no
right now not now you're bringing no no
after all of this is done okay let's get
out of that first that's our goal yeah
get out of debt build your emergency
fund and then you can start piling up
cash and build you a house with cash
okay that sounds amazing because if you
don't make payments you're gonna have
this thing called money because you make
130 000 a year
right
okay so um
what do i need to do today until my book
gets here the correct book gets here
well here's what i want you to do you're
are you doing a budget on paper right
now excel what are you doing
on paper hand write it in paper have a
big yellow binder that stays on top of
the the book that's coming your way i'm
going to gift you ramsey plus that
includes every dollar premium and
financial peace university and so in the
meantime what i want you to do is start
your every dollar budget this is digital
it's going to be easier to track than
pen and paper and i think that's going
to do better for you and watch all the
videos in financial peace university on
top of that until the book gets there
the book is fantastic and it's financial
universities
financial peace universities better if i
could recommend one thing and you're
willing to do it that's those nine
lessons so tonight we're gonna sign you
up tonight you and your husband watch
the first lesson okay and download the
every dollar app and start your budget
tonight on the every dollar okay and the
both of you now you really have to be
committed to the vision of this
and it's a life change situation but
it's gonna set you free if you do it
okay
because you got to get tired of being
tired
i am so tired of living like this
very much though yeah
hey you got this
place is up from here pam we're rooting
for you hang on we're going to uh austin
will pick up and get you signed up you
know i spoke to a group the other day
and um and i got to listen to
a group of uh guys and gals that had
come through a drug rehab center
and what they said was um
four different ones got up and they've
been clean and dry for two three four
years got their life back you know got
got to see their children again their
children have been taken away from them
everything else these were hardcore drug
addicts
uh crack heroin
you know everything and they were
completely dry and completely cleaned up
and i got to listen to them and then i
talked to them a little bit afterwards
and every one of them said and the guy
working the running the rehab center
said uh the people that get clean and
stay clean all share one thing they
always at some point say
i'm tired
i'm exhausted
i've been running from
these drugs
or to these drugs for so long
and the ones that are ready to change
say i'm tired so when someone says i'm
sick and tired of being sick and tired
like she said she's tired of this
that's always over that's a great
indicator no she's not doing heroin
that helps too but she's i mean the
point you're right but the point is that
that it's all behavior change and
behavior changes behavior change i mean
if you look down and you go i'm tired of
being fat you know i got you know i
looked down i'd gained a whole bunch of
weight eating donuts during covet and i
said i'm tired of being fat i'm tired
and i was physically tired too but
that's when life change starts there's
that but you can google how to get out
of debt but doing it's the hard part
yeah i mean everybody knows what to do
the knowledge is how do you lose weight
you eat less and you exercise more away
from the donuts ramsay get away from the
donuts boy i'll slap it out of your hand
if i see one all right i'll see how that
goes for me yeah see how that works out
for you